could there be as a result a kind of
soft landing which is a slow
depreciation uh or you know inflation
whichever way you look at it
but either side of the coin which which
is kind of a manageable way out of this
big debt load when you have so much
debt that is also somebody's stored
wealth
um either the debtor or the creditor is
going to pay and it becomes very very
difficult to balance those two things
for central banks that's why lot that's
the challenge about having a lot of data
which is a lot of financial assets
because that balancing act becomes
difficult so i think that right now um
we have a problem in that a high enough
interest rate
to
adequately
control inflation or provide an adequate
return to inflation is too high of an
interest rate
for the capital markets and for the
economy so i believe that we're entering
a period which it's going to be very
very difficult for the fed and for other
central banks to try to find that right
balance they're going to navigate
between those two things uh too tight
means
a bad economy and too loose means a bad
inflation i think that difference is
going to produce more of a stagflation
type of environment
this particularly true internationally
because internationally a lot of the
world is holding bonds because it's a
reserve currency if you want to save in
a bond if you want to save in dollars
because you use it so much you buy it
and you save it and you buy the bonds
but they're overweighted in dollars so
it's not certain
uh but it is a big big risk that i think
everybody's too casual about